how much do you really know about the
elusive natasha romanov before i worked
for shield
i made a name for myself when it was
time to assemble the avengers who did
shield call let me put you on hold
former kgb assassin agent of shield and
avenger
she fought through the battle of new
york squared off against the winter
soldier
defended the world against ultron she
signed the sokovia accords
dealt with all that fallout and beat
back the forces of thanos
when all seemed lost she held the team
together but
how well do you really know her it's
time for her story
i've lived a lot of lives
you've been waiting for this
you don't know everything about me
i've lived a lot of lives
[Music]
before i was an avenger
before i got this family
i made mistakes choosing
between what the world wants you to be
and who you are
we have to go back to where it all
started
where did you think i was all this time
[Music]
we have unfinished business
my girls are the toughest girls in the
world i'm sorry
we had our orders and we played our role
it wasn't real
it was real to me
to me you were everything
right
[Music]
she's
[Music]
one thing's for sure
i'm done running for my past
[Music]
you